columbus has like columbus is like the
beatles of exploring right
like they're just the ones you know or
if you're like what was the
what's the biggest rock band of all time
you'd be like oh the beatles that's just
what columbus is like people
they teach them to everybody so
everyone's like oh it's clump like
i literally thought columbus sailed here
yeah
saw it went back and was like there's a
whole land and everyone's like cool
cool yeah america the way they teach you
in school there's
there's never any violence there's never
any [ __ ] torture or rape or slavery
yeah just kind of like
so columbus sailed here with three ships
the painter
the meena and the santa fe everyone's
like i know all of them and they're like
then you know
yeah i'm like i'm like i had an aunt
nina yeah
right santa maria and everyone's like
yeah yeah
and then if you get 1492 they're like
that's it you get an a in history
yeah and then like and then as you start
to go on like as like you know time goes
on you're like oh wait there was some
evil [ __ ] that happened like
you know i remember i like took a class
and uh like a college professor just
casually through it and he's like yeah
columbus is one of the first people to
experiment with biological warfare and i
was like huh
it was like hey he gave blankets filled
with smallpox the native americans
i was like oh what sister old mary never
told us that
what about the ocean blue in 1492. i'm
like wait so he killed every i'm like
but they have vaccines right he's like
no
they killed half the population but
that's what you have to do for our
country i was like oh
or for me it's falling asleep at 33 to
an episode of ancient aliens
smoking a joint and then waking up and
they were like columbus raped
most of the women and you're like what's
up
what's going on because you realize that
he yeah he basically brought the
spaniards to be like yo grab some people
what are you doing because that that was
like big business back then and then
um you know but it's interesting because
like in certain neighborhoods like here
we're in bay ridge brooklyn and this is
like a pretty conservative neighborhood
i remember i have a friend my big big
ryan
he's a cop lives in bay ridge and i
remember like a couple years ago when
they were
changing one well i guess they have now
legally changed it to
indigenous people's day right like it's
not called columbus day or it still
is in new york they say they celebrate
both they sell but
but in like another city it's just
indigenous peoples
or it's just columbus certain states and
certain cities
just um recognize it as columbus day and
other cities and states
recognize it as both and some people
just do indigenous peoples
got it that's so funny it's like
sexuality in this country
where there's there's still you know
like cities that are like man and woman
sanctity of marriage and then there's
some people like listen if you're bi
that's just what you are if you want to
be a columbus if you want to be
indigenous
and there's other people that are like
honey we're coming hot gay sex
right here it's indigenous people's day
like that's
what it is because there's
the thing about americans that uh
ultimately is a weakness for us
is we latch on to narratives
and anyone that tries to change that
narrative we're immediately like you're
attacking
everything i love right where it's like
nah not really we're just trying to
clarify some certain specific things
yeah i think like the problem is with
like looking back in history like things
with columbus
is like you're gonna find everybody was
in in today's standards a piece of [ __ ]
back then everybody was doing what he
was doing these [ __ ]
the dudes were wearing these hot wigs
yeah just
sailing selling people into slavery yeah
and just [ __ ]
raping and pillaging yeah cause a mat
look at how quick
the world changes and like i i remember
like the movie waiting
came out on netflix and i've seen
waiting a bunch of times but it just
came out on netflix you know with uh
with uh ryan reynolds justin long yeah
it's a great question
but then the whole premise of the movie
is if you get stuck
if you get caught with uh looking at
another employee's dick they play a game
looking at another guy's dick
they kick you in the ass for being and
it's like that was a number one comedy
movie just
10 15 years ago and now if you came to
that premise you'd get canceled
just for trying to pitch that dude if
you tried doing that at an applebee's
now
no that they'd be like you're out you're
out dude we can't have you at the beach
so imagine in 1492 hundreds of years ago
the things that they were doing which
were they didn't realize that they were
doing hard i mean they probably did but
it was just like
business was business back then yeah
dude and that's what it is so it's like
if you want to go back and cancel
everybody it's like guess what it wasn't
just
old white explorers that were doing bad
[ __ ] everybody every human being was
living a different life
with the way like america is you know
now
like even white people it's interesting
giannis
and i giannis read the article and then
he told me about it it was fascinating
that
actually like you know like we're all
created equal it's like
there's scientific proof now they
believe that that's actually not true
like we
both like europeans and people more
northern
from more northern countries come from a
different
strand of chimpanzee dna than people
more south so it was like two slightly
different
but slightly different but actual
different types of human beings that's
what they think
this it's all pre you know early signs
but the northern
european dna the one like that mostly
white people are from
is like 10 times more vicious chimp
than the southern ones i would call 100
believe so that's why it's like a
european settler coming in being vicious
this article is saying there's
scientific evidence that potentially
very early stages
backs all that up it's like white people
are just more
evil because of their dna so yeah that's
what they said
white people are the pitbull of
humans yeah where he's just like if
there's an uh if there's an unmanned
white person that walks in
what is he gonna do yeah what's he gonna
do yeah can you really trust him i feel
like
he rescues a snap yeah you know like i
don't know
i don't know that a rottweiler walks
they were like he's the problem
that's not a big deal he thinks like
america's not innocent you know that
doesn't make me say i want to hate
america
it's just good to learn but these things
like there are these over correctness
where it's like
really now we're gonna fight about
indigenous people's day it's like just
[ __ ] shut up just kind of admit that
there's blood on our hands
yeah that helps the whole situation it's
also like when you see a good marriage
like a really good marriage yeah and
they had this honesty where they're like
yeah she was a [ __ ] for like 10 years
yeah and now we're great now we're like
and you're going like that kind of
[ __ ] it gets me going yeah she's like
what do you want me to do i [ __ ] this
brother and that was ten years yeah
whatever
we're doing i think this gets his yeah
and you're like i love her god i love
her but they
they just acknowledge a shared history
where [ __ ] and that's what it is it's
like calling indigenous people's day or
columbus day that shouldn't be a fight
like that shouldn't be like i'm taking a
stand on one or the other it's stupid
it's entitlement it makes us feel like
it made this i don't know this year
if you'll have such a stink about what
it's going to be called because now
we're in a [ __ ] pandemic yeah
so it's like now it's like the same
thing it's like now
nobody cares we were saying this last
podcast like nobody cares about the
straws anymore
nobody cares if there's plastic being
used on the ventilator that could
strangle the turret but this is that's
that's kind of just the exact prime
example of what all this [ __ ] is it's
like
i bet native americans don't really give
a [ __ ] about the indigenous
people's day as much as they i'm not
speaking for them but i'm saying like
look at the dakota pipeline you look at
[ __ ] dude look at sturgis this year
sturgis happens in the black hills of
south dakota okay which is lakota nation
okay it's it that is still that's like
their most sacred land
and sturgis is a part and they had like
uh 300 000 people without masks during
kovid just being like
whatever and it was the protests of the
natives that were there that were like
dude [ __ ] this
yeah why are you guys coming in is
bringing that this is you're doing it
again
you're doing the thing again yeah where
you're bringing a disease in when we're
telling you we don't want you here we're
like
hold on i gotta see [ __ ] smash mouth
outside without a piece of libtard cloth
on my face yeah it's like i'm where i
might as well be wearing somebody's
foreskin on my face
if you just want to see history repeat
itself go read up about
about the sioux nation protesting
sturgis rally this year the bike rally
because it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
fat people with hepatitis b
i don't believe in that hey you guys
suck just
you're the problem yeah it's not like um
you're doing the lead i don't know man i
just that that bugged me like reading
that because you're like man you guys
are just doing the same thing
the same thing but you're just acting
like but it's my rights
i'm supposed i go to sturgis every year
and i watch my
wife my fat wife get gang-banged by the
hell's angels
and then i go home then i go home and i
listen to legion of skanks yeah with
shout out legion escape shout out legion
um but see the
the whole reason why because a lot of
people like oh we've never even met a
native american why do we care that's on
purpose the united states government in
the 19th century
adopted a policy to isolate and
concentrate native americans in places
with few natural resources far from con
far from you know contact with the
developing u.s economy
because they knew that their land that
they were living on had all the [ __ ]
they were like let's just move them over
here
and we'll you know their new home
they'll forget about their their old
home
and they'll like their new home and now
they just all live on for the most part
reservations
uh making arizona iced tea i've thought
about this
what makes you [ __ ] does anything make
you [ __ ] as much as when you drink a
[ __ ]
can of 99 cents arizona iced tea
honestly i'm i'm too adapted to it
it's just fine i can i it's been a while
yeah until i found out how much sugar
was actually there but i used to rip
those green teas
oh dude i used to drink the raspberry
iced teas and then just let
it rip i mean [ __ ] my pants it was crazy
yeah i thought the green teas were
healthy
no i genuinely thought the arizona green
peas
i for four years of my life i
scientifically were like yeah this is
like a healthy green tea i'm like yeah
are getting chamomile and
zinc and stuff do they have arizona iced
tea anymore do they make it or i just
don't look for it anymore oh they make
it i guess because like once you grow up
and you realize how much sugar is in
like your mind is always like don't ever
go near that like mountain dew
like did they stop making mountain dew
it's like no your brain just left just
says you can't have that so it's out
because you're a kid you're like yeah no
but they got they got new flavors now
dude of mountain dew
oh yeah they got yeah you got baja blast
you got [ __ ] oh
you can get into it dude multiple
flavors but
it's thank you so much for watching hope
you enjoyed the last video
don't forget to tell your friends like
subscribe and turn on notifications oh